[music]
LUCY REEDER: When I came to
Princeton, I was looking for a
way to volunteer in the community.
I decided to do something that
I've never done before and I
never thought I could do.
I'm leaving Princeton knowing
that I can do anything.
[music]
BENJAMIN COGAN: I worked in a boys' orphanage
in New Delhi, India.
ALEXANDRIA ("CAMMIE") BROWN: I tutored middle school
students in Trenton, N.J.
AMANDA REES: I taught a course on energy, environment and
entrepreneurship in Bagamoyo, Tanzania.
FAAEZ UL HAQ: I worked on a
crowd-sourcing system for
tracking corruption in public offices in
the developing world.
YU-SUNG HUANG: I spent a summer
helping New York City
figure out how it can help
failing small businesses.
ALAN UTRIA: I worked with an NGO in
South Africa called Nkanyiso.
ARIELLE SANDOR: I was an enactor
in a magnet theater troop in
Nakuru, Kenya.
JAVARIA NAJEEB: I made a documentary about a
transgender person.
EDUARDO CONTIJOCH: I led a
breakout trip to Washington, DC,
to look at HIV/AIDS issues in the district.
LUCY REEDER: I volunteered with
the Princeton Fire Department.
[music]
LUCY REEDER: We got one call at 6 a.m., in
December, for a structure fire
out in Hopewell.
We really didn't know what to
expect until we came over a
hill and we could see the house,
on the top of the hill,
completely engulfed in flames.
And I expected to feel nervous
but I was actually calm
because I knew that I had been
trained to know everything
that I needed to know to get the job done.
[music]
EDUARDO CONTIJOCH: Meeting
individuals who were HIV-
positive, seeing that their
lives weren't just the fact
that they had an infection,
it really brought
the issue to life.
ARIELLE SANDOR: Magnet theater
is a means of engaging a
community in an issue that
they're facing internally
through theater, and then halfway
through the skit we'll
say, "OK, freeze point."
"What would you guys do if you
were in this position?"
[music]
JAVARIA NAJEEB: I took a class
titled "Social Issue Filmmaking."
The great thing about being at
Princeton is that there's a
lot of collaboration between the
different departments, so
my class was a combination of
many different kinds of
perspectives in one classroom,
which is something that
Princeton offers to all
its students.
ARIELLE SANDOR: Princeton was
the reason that I found out
about magnet theater and, you
know, it's those connections,
it's those random conversations, those
appointments you schedule on
e-mail and you don't know how
they're going to impact you, and
then it's like [finger-snap] everything
is just so different.
[music]
FAAEZ UL HAQ: To think that this
could potentially have a
positive impact somewhere in the world,
that's a really--
that's a really great feeling.
AMANDA REES: In the Dalai Lama Fellowship,
when we talk about takeaways, it's really like a greater
understanding of compassion
and resilience and interconnectedness.
YU-SUNG HUANG: Now, when I walk
through the streets of New
York, I see a very human side
behind every small business.
JAVARIA NAJEEB: This gave me
a broader perspective of how
the human condition is the same everywhere.
ALEXANDRIA ("CAMMIE") BROWN: I saw children
come in who were very
shy, and the children really
starting to get into the
stories and I saw confidence
levels soar.
BENJAMIN COGAN: I've been
inspired to start a global
poverty charity called Giving
What We Can, that both
encourages students to give
more to global poverty
charities and to give to the most
effective charities possible.
[music]
ALAN UTRIA: You get to go out
into the world and really
learn things you can't learn
in classrooms, and while
you're doing that hopefully, you
can also have an impact on
the communities that you are working with.
LUCY REEDER: There are many
different ways to make a
difference, and you should
think about all of them
because you'll never know what
you'll be able to do.
ALEXANDRIA ("CAMMIE") BROWN: Anything that you can imagine, you can do here.
ARIELLE SANDOR: There are so
many opportunities to get
involved, and it's just about
taking that first step, and
somehow, you'll find maybe five,
and you'll be able to
link them all together and
create this incredible path
that you never would have
imagined before.
ALEXANDRIA ("CAMMIE") BROWN: If you have
something that you're
passionate about, something that
you're interested in, if
you see a problem, then you can
really make a change and you
can make a difference.
[music]